also also take pictures so like so you
can show my mom
that was already here so
um I'm super happy to talk in in pycon
it's my first time approaching this
particular Community I've done uh it
I've done talks with other communities
but I've been a great group of
individuals and and I see a lot of
innovation going
um going on both in in data science and
and in development front right so uh
just as a quick introduction my name is
Luis Fernando Alvarez I'm an engineering
manager stack Builders our company
focuses mostly on functional programming
I'm happy to talk about that after after
the talk because it's a big topic I have
a few years of experience in the
industry I come from Ecuador this is 10
000 kilometers away and I'm going back
this next weekend so it's been a long
trip and um and yeah I do all sorts of
languages and a bunch of of stuff I am a
musician as well so so yeah follow me on
on my social media I think
I think you'll see some interesting
things
and as a disclaimer I don't consider
myself to be an expert in Python I I
have been focused most of my life in in
JavaScript I have been able to
participate in a couple complex python
projects but the aim of the socket just
to present a few tools that I find a bit
useful in the path to connect an
application to external Services right
so let's start so this is your
application This Little Light line is
your application it's a it's it's it's
super small in the in in just
comparatively right to whatever you have
on on the rest of the world and
um and in time you want to make it grow
and and it lacks right now a lot of
Natural Resources you just have a little
house and couple trees but you have two
ways to go in this in this sense right
you have two choices like in The Matrix
right red pill blue pill so you have the
first one which is investing a lot of
money and investing a lot of of
resources into exploring your Island and
best sourcing uh sourcing those those
resources from from inside or you could
just start importing and foreign
resources right bringing them from other
services or pushing them to other
services and just offloading that kind
of work so here's where external
Services come in right this is a big
external service and a lot of consumers
going into that service
and as developers as you know we build
things with one thing in mind which is
challenging ourselves to build the next
big product right the most complex stuff
that probably I won't need
so uh but businesses don't don't work
like that right time and money are super
limited the business uh requirements
change every day and and most of the
time it's a matter of building faster
than your competitors and and and as a
side note I I think this is what makes
what difference is a good engineer from
a great engineer right it's having a
clear picture where the business is
going and taking pragmatic decisions on
top of that instead of just using what's
hip or using what uh what is what
everyone's using right
and building fast is easy most of the
time but building fast while maintaining
the good standards and having a
resilience system is not as easy as as
as as it it looks right so talking about
these external Services we have a few
considerations
we have uncertainty on these systems
will I be able to connect to the other
system has other has something changed
in the other system lately because
external life apis and distributed
programming on concept is unreliable
right even if they guarantee you
99.95 of uptime is uh sometimes it's
going to fail right so A good rule of
thumb would be to distrust everything
right even things that you've built even
the apis that you built you should
distrust those as well I distrust mine
more than the external ones sometimes
and you have also a very varied
ecosystem and and you have
non-standardization which is an issue
right some apis return Json responses
some are soap API some are rest API some
of graphql and uh and not everyone uses
the same standards right some use
correct uh correct codes some don't so
you
um so these operations might be exposed
to a non-conventional means right and
and the documentation that's Hit or Miss
sometimes you have good documentation
sometimes you don't
uh apis are also hard to test and since
we have that
99.95 percent of time on our minds then
and under the hood we think that they
shouldn't be tested right and testing it
is expensive and not really
straightforward
and uh and security is a big Point I've
I've been going through an ISO
certification process which is uh which
is a time consuming process and and has
gotten me thinking are we running risk
assessment on every integration that we
want to build into our systems and that
is something to think about right how do
we track the changes how is my data
going to be handled in this in these
services so we're going to try and and
explore some of the concepts that help
us mitigate some of these issues right
and hopefully survive the process of
integration who has integrated
previously with with external systems
a lot of people a lot of traumatized
people sorry
awesome so first
um
first tool that we have on our hands
right it's caching and you might have
seen this this phrase before but ninety
percent of the time it's been aimed at
the naming things is hard right so now
we're going going to focus on caching
and what is caching is just storing a
subset of the data in my own system
right
um so I won't do a lot of calls calls to
the back end I won't do a lot of calls
to the external system and the goal the
end goal is to reduce them right in in
some in some way and then I can later
efficiently reuse this data right
considering it might not be the latest
data because it's it's something that
that I consumed in the past but uh but
yeah that's that's a risk we have to
live with sometimes
and uh and
there's a trade-off here because we have
high speed on when consuming this data
but we have low capacity we are not
going to pull everything from the API to
our local environment right or our our
servers
and thankfully there is just a lot of of
different backends that I can use to to
do this like memcache red is database
file system every system is different
right and every every requirement is
different so for this
um there are a couple strategies that we
could that we could follow
so one of them would be the cash aside
strategy which is I think the most
common strategy
um it works in three steps you try to
read from cash if it's not found read
from the data source and uh when you've
read from the data source you write back
that data to the cache right for next
consumption
um some some Key Parts here I've used
Django in this example a few the caching
system in Django but it's super similar
using other libraries right
I want you to notice the third argument
to cache.set which is almost at the end
which is the timeout right and here's
where it's key for you to know the
business for you to know how often
should you pull this data how urgently
do you need this data right here it's
set to every 10 minutes which means the
data would go stale every 10 minutes and
this would work for applications that
don't need uh like real-time data right
and it's going to give you this 10
minute safety net
um
if the requirements I've had to
implement systems where I've had to set
a longer term cache let's say a cash on
top of another right and one cache that
keeps the data for 24 hours and that
would give me a few more hours to to
solve any issues that I had with the
external service
um and that's that's kind of your your
final safety net right
so here's this is the strategy when
you're pulling data and then when you're
trying to write back data uh it's useful
sometimes to batch updates right and
this obviously assumes that you have a
way to process that batch information in
the endpoint
um so this is this is also simple enough
uh what I what I'm doing here is just
getting the what is in cash appending
more customers to that cache and then
setting that cash back and at some point
maybe with a crown job maybe with a with
a scheduled job I will send those cat
that cash to to the remote yeah so look
at that little boat go with a lot of
stones
great so as with everything in
technology every this has its issues the
first risk that I've already mentioned
is having stale data right in some cases
it might be fine but it won't work very
well for data and real-time data and
applications
um
there's a lot of complexity that you add
when you when you add these things right
to your system
and these are not things that Junior
developers think about the match maybe
we are all uh or most of us are
experienced developers and haven't have
done this in the past but uh but in the
end you write code for other developers
to read and sometimes you need that that
Clarity uh for for more Junior
developers security uh it's what I
mentioned right how am I uh taking care
of my information uh most databases are
encrypted and my data that goes to the
database goes encrypted but most cache
back-ends are not encrypted and I could
suffer an attack from there right
um so a a general recommendation here
would be to encrypt things before
putting it into cash and maybe when you
try to process you decrypt it some comma
libraries in Python just to to deal with
uh with these things right
and caching so anyone cures why there's
a long line of boats over there
um
it's it's kind of like traffic in my
hometown but
um
but but no I'm going to talk about a
task queuing right asynchronous task
queuing
which is which is uh interesting because
um as a as a JavaScript developer in the
past I've this was one of the easier
concepts for me in Python because I was
I was trained in the dark arts of the
asynchronous
so the main idea is that you have to
alleviate the load in your main thread
JavaScript being a single thread
language you don't want to block that
main thread so for that you need to deal
a lot with asynchronicity right and and
just do deferred operations
Network calls are very expensive
computationally speaking and they take
some time
so uh in some applications this is okay
you can make your user wait a bit in
other cases not so much right so instead
of trying to process everything on the
main thread we are going to put some of
those expensive operations in a queue
right and and process it later because
we need to keep that cycle unblocked
so uh let's think about this for a bit
right if we're going to make calls from
our main application Network calls and
something fails what are we going to do
we're going to stop the system we're
going to absorb the error we're going to
make the user wait and then just pop up
a big a big error screen there
um so these are synchronous task
processors are going to help us to retry
some of the failed calls and thankfully
there's a lot of things that we that we
can do for that right
um there's just a bunch of libraries
that do this and python we'll go over
this the list later but the the main
operation here is you just enqueue an
operation you process it later and then
most of these systems can do auto retry
if the operation fails right
so you have a little a little code
example here you are creating a
connection you are creating a queue
which is a a line of tasks that will get
processed in the future uh
one thing to consider is as you can see
the third argument is the retry
mechanism here so you have three retries
with three intervals which would give
you if the remote system fails you can
just send retries over there
uh another thing another important thing
is that on the
the first argument to enqueue there it's
update customer right and in Python you
have functions that work as a Citizens
First Class citizens right and what does
this mean that functions in Python can
be passed to other functions or can be
returned from functions so it's not a
reference of the function it's not
um like the the the string name of the
function it is the actual function right
and this is important bear with me on
this one because next slide we can see
some issues that we can have in in task
queuing right again the complexity
increase
and again the security because you are
having that information put into another
place right you're not putting into a
database you're putting that into
somewhere that someone can tap in and
consume
uh but uh one of the one of the key
things here is I've had in the past with
some of the libraries maybe not of I
haven't tried all of these uh in in
other languages I've had some of these
issues as well
but it can be a source of Errors what
happens if for example you enqueue a
function you and Q
an operation that should be done later
uh and and in this case you are sending
the actual function that you want to
execute but in some other cases you
would send in other libraries you would
send the text name of the function and
this would be problematic because if you
run a deployment and you had all of the
you deployed production and you have
elements in the queue that need to be
processed then uh it's going to look for
the like that function in your code base
and that function might have changed
over time so it could could get you um
could get we could have problems over
there and um and regarding security
issues uh here's a super simple way of
encrypting things and just put that in
the in the queue and um yeah this is
using just fernet
awesome so another technique is just
using an API abstraction layer right uh
this might be super obvious to some a
bit but as well there's there's just a
lot of of people with different levels
of expertise so what's the API
abstraction layer what what is an
abstraction again it's uh I I usually
run a a a a a Talk inside my company
which is called Tech concepts for
non-technical people and the the best
way to define this and the best way to
make them understand what is an
abstraction is hiding the weirdness
right we are trying to hide the
weirdness from the external systems or
the apis or the sdks that we are that we
are
um doing right so in this case we're
going to hide things like authentication
throttling encoding encryption things
like that we want to hide that and we
want the implementation to be as
straightforward as possible right for
the one that is consuming that
so this means wrapping our API calls or
external sdks with classes of our own
which make them more maintainable right
so it helps in many ways one of the
biggest ways in which it helps is having
our system
not tightly coupled right with a
particular implementation if someday we
want to switch an implementation and
switch to another service it's it's
rather easy to do
and the dependency injection is a key
concept to achieve this right
so this is uh just a little example uh
you can see over there on the left a
client and not very well implemented
client which uh just sources everything
uh on its own but on the right you are
injecting those properties into those
into those clients and you are even
injecting that that client into the
consumer so it it makes it super
flexible right what you would have to do
is inherit from that client if you want
to use that in the future and heard from
that that client and add the specific
behaviors for uh for each of the
functions right that you want to
implement
so it's easier to swap and test we're
going to talk about it later and easier
to maintain the code in feature
and this is what I was talking about
right the left example uh it's it's
going to be it's going to require a lot
of changes if any endpoint or the base
URL change uh on the right you just feed
that information to the client and you
just abstract those into into inner
functions right
um
so that's about maintenance
so as everything it has issues it's not
a silver bullet depends on the business
use cases and how often do we plan to
change Integrations we might never need
to change an integration on on our
system
and we might be preemptively optimizing
things which we are not going to need
right so it's it's always about knowing
the business and how it works
and finally I'm going to talk about
testing and observability right which is
which is very important if I can control
external systems and they're
particularly unreliable I need to take a
decision if I'm going to use them and
how I'm going to use them
so
um so external systems are not reliable
some of them have slas some some of them
have better ways of guaranteeing this
than others but some don't right and
besides coding defensively which we've
done and helping our system to deal with
the unexpected I think we need to have
better observability on these services
and this happens through uh continuous
integration processes for example we can
cover some of those external apis with
integration tests this we can add with
monitoring using tools like like air
brake like data talk roll bar
and and also that this is another case
sometimes services are very are very
sneaky apis change right and our our
external Services might push changes
onto us that might not be documented
sometimes that's a big problem some of
them have a very orderly process to
change them they provide the change logs
the version history and backwards
compatibility and and a bunch of stuff
right
but some may not provide that so this is
also a driving Factor when choosing an
external service
uh a general rule of thumb is if you
have an SDK use it because those are
usually very well maintained and they
are very well documented and you can
pull the just a new version easily right
through your CI process
and as a good local practice every
integration you make should have models
or type hinting right you can use
pedantic you can use mypai and uh this
way you know what to expect and and just
be better at dealing with errors
and one thing that that I should say is
that you should test on sandboxes when
possible right if your service offers a
Sandbox it's way better to just connect
to that sandbox instead of of testing
look at that look at that awesome
sandbox on fire even the water is on
fire in that in that sandbox
but uh but what you would do is just
create a specific client for for the
sandbox as you can see the class sandbox
client which inherits for from client
right and then you have that ignite
water function and then you can abstract
that that behavior and when you're
testing which is the part below you can
inject that client into your into your
functions right or you can inject that
into to another object and just test the
behavior of that
and uh what happens if there's not if
there's no sandbox right uh I think
Market mocking it is the best the best
way right
one particular thing with MOX that I
that I I might not agree completely with
and that's why I'm suggesting uh
sandboxes is that they have to be
maintained over time and uh and your
your continuous integration tool might
be saying that everything is perfect
everything is working because your mock
is working as as you coded it because
tests need to be maintained as well but
the live API could be failing and the
other the only way to know that is to to
connect to uh to a live service
right so then you can see some useful
tools over there
um
and uh yeah as you can see there we have
created a local client which uh what it
does is just exposes these fake
customers
um variable this is similar to a fixture
so disadvantages of testing because
everything has disadvantages
no testing has no disadvantage maybe
that they take some upfront time to set
up right but would you rather spend that
time
debugging that later I think it's and
and that's where the the sleepless
nights come right would you want to do
it in a control way or would you like to
debug that at 2 am I'm not not sure
which I prefer
so um and and also adding systems adding
tests into a system that doesn't have
them it's going to be a bit hard and
it's going to take a while right
um if if you have a system a legacy
system in which you want to put some
tests in my Approach usually is to code
a lot of integration tests right and
just cover the basic cases
and then start adding the lower level
tests but it's but it's key to know that
not every test is is the same and and
you can use several types of tests for
your for your system there's there's uh
there's going to be a awesome talks on
on tests and there have been these days
awesome talks about testing through
pycon
so as final considerations
um the the first part distrust
everything right even even your own code
because because we are human when when
you when you code your own apis uh
usually you have to code all of the all
of the cases right all of the error
cases all the
um all the different combinations of
those error cases and the messages so
it's going to be hard to test uh for
that
um yeah property testing is is a good is
a good fit there
um and not everything we discussed today
will apply to all systems it's about
knowing the business it's about knowing
what to uh what where your business is
going where where the direction is is
going right so you don't just Implement
things that you are not going to use
a good thing is make an inventory of
your data how often do you need to
update it and how critical it is to your
system if that information would be
outdated right
um and always make sure that your
fallback mechanisms and ways to retry
are there in the no in the code also we
haven't talked about throttling too much
but throttling is is in essence just
spacing out the connections you make to
an external service
and this is helpful just uh just because
you don't want to um to cover all of
your your uh your rates or your quotas
and the services
in general I think this is a more more
of a life advice follow the test pyramid
and Implement different kinds of tests
right based based on your use cases it
doesn't make sense to just Implement a
test suite and and bump up that uh that
um that test coverage number test
coverage means nothing if you're testing
everything that you shouldn't test
so that is that is kind of my suggestion
so I think this is the questions part
[Applause]
that's an amazing presentation
especially the slides so we have a
couple of questions precisely too so the
first one is how did you create those
nice Graphics in the beginning
that's not me I always get that just
download its price sheet from the
internet and and spend sleepless nights
working on the presentation
this is amazing and the second question
is why should we use Python task kui
queue
ah instead of async iOS I think a weight
event Loop for asynchronous cities I
mean that's so so many I think that I
got I think so yeah so there's there's
just a bunch of of different methods
that that you can use right and and
again I I think the the question is what
do you want to achieve if one is easier
than the other to implement and to
maintain over time choose that one if if
your team is small you're not going to
choose a big a big tool for that and a
big complex thing because it's it's just
a liability for you so I think it's uh I
think it's more about uh following
common sense and and being pragmatic
about things right
as as a developer I've been in that
situation that
um that I wanted to we say in Spanish
which is which is
um invent warm water right it's
it's there you have to just use whatever
tools you have for the for the job there
is a new question in your stack where do
you see the central truth example API
specification use cases sorry I didn't
get the purpose part uh in your stack
where do you see the central truth
in my stack sorry where do you see the
central truth
the central Truth uh so I think the
source of truth would be the remote
system if you're connecting and pulling
data from there that's that will be your
source of fruit so caching what what it
does is just bring that part of of the
truth it might have changed in the
remote but you have to kind of uh give
or take right what what are you
expecting are you expecting that data to
be 100 there always or or can it wait
right or is it updated if once every day
with a bad job then then then I think
that's uh that's your source of Truth
the remote one
yeah so I think there are no more
questions
so let's sorry let's thank the speaker
again Louise
[Applause]